now we kick off the weekend with
best-selling author Michael Lewis on his
latest book on the creation of
behavioral economics the undoing project
Oh
hello everyone hello everyone good
evening and welcome to this latest in
conversation with event at Stern
my name is Mervyn King and my guest this
evening is quite simply the most
successful nonfiction author in the
world
Michael Lewis of his 13 titles from
liars poker to flash boys from Moneyball
to the big short every single one has
been a best-seller his latest book the
undoing project is published this week
please give a warm welcome to Michael
Lewis thank you money is this on for
good all right splendid now Michael this
sum this is point out to me is
subliminal it's okay this is the way you
try to achieve superiority in the
interview context so most of your books
have been about slightly old people
unusual quirky people who've defied the
conventional wisdom this time you've
written about two college professors why
have you written about to college
academics so the books never start with
I want to write a book about this or
that it would happen was this I kept
crawfished into this story over a period
of years a book I wrote called Moneyball
came out in 2003 that book was
ostensibly about baseball but what was
really about in my mind was the way
markets can misjudge miss value people
and this team the Oakland A's had
figured that out and because they lack
resources they found new and better ways
to to value the players than existed and
it meant what they were doing basically
was replacing the intuitive judgment of
the so-called experts with analysis of
the performance statistics that was just
better that we identified and identified
somatic mistakes that the experts made
in the valuing the players using
business school research exactly
if Business School actually research the
research they were using was it wasn't
as if they had proprietary information
you could have gotten the stuff off the
web but nobody pay attention to it
because they trusted their experts
Miller II really believe that the
experts didn't know so this book comes
out and an economist and a lawyer
together reviewed the book in The New
Republic Richard Taylor who's a
well-known economist and Cass Sunstein
and they said in this review it was a
that might they liked my book and so on
and so forth but I seem to I seemed not
to know that that there were these two
Israeli psychologists who had explained
why the experts got it wrong that they
antenna to Israeli psychologist Danny
Kahneman and Amos Tversky had done work
showing the systematic biases the mind
was prone to when it was making
intuitive judgments and I'd never heard
I mean so we got a clear day here for a
second Mervin was my tutor at the London
School of Economics when I was a
graduate student and he's partly
responsible for me not ever having heard
of Jani and Amos as a result I was not
the most distinguished student it is the
but but in any case I didn't want to
burden you would do you know better show
anyway so did we have a long history and
if we later on if you want to get into
it I'm happy to get into it but but and
so I but I never heard these guys and
and I thought I file their way
I went actually looked them up on the
web saw the Danny Kahneman won the Nobel
Prize in Economics even though there's a
psychologist in 2002 and then that
that's interesting I have a drinking
buddy in Berkeley so it's not books come
about my drinking buddy is a
psychologist named Acker Keltner very
well-known psychologist you see his
field of the motion but he was Amos
Tversky whose teaching assistant and he
was friends with Dan economist and then
one night over drinks I said you know
it's always bothering me this is now
about 2005 that I didn't get the story
that I told the story about this
baseball and I never got to why the heck
personal making mistakes and he said
well Danny had the house up the hill and
I have a dream a look yeah and I said
this was back I still had must have
thought in 2005 that Nobel Prize winners
and economics were unapproachable as
opposed to self publicizing and and so I
was tentative about it but I called him
up he said come on up and have coffee
and we started a friendship
I would go for long walks in the
Berkeley Hills and that in the
friendship at that point there's a
longer answer than you want but this is
the answer was based upon me helping him
sort through the crisis of confidence he
was experiencing writing his book
Thinking Fast and Slow which is sold I
don't know how many millions of copies
now but which he was sure the moment was
published would destroy his reputation
it was wonderful he was this welter of
self-doubt and I mean like I had never
seen and he was in the process when I
met him of paying people friends to book
to go and find people to pay who he
would not see so they'd be blind
reviewers to write him anonymous reviews
persuading him not to publish his book
because it would ruin his reputation I
mean this was it was crazy and so my job
was go up every six weeks eight weeks
and say it's great do it and in the
course of this conversation I just was
interested in him he started talking
about this relationship he had with Amos
Tversky and it was love it was a love
story it was in the most amazing love
story it wasn't sexual but it didn't for
these guys as I've said people have
asked for the one-line movie summary of
this book it's Brokeback Mountain but
they screw each other's ideas and and
and that's what it felt like I felt like
I was listening to that the guys and
Brokeback Mountain talked about each
other and and at some point I thought
this is this the emotion of this thing
is really interesting and that it had an
arc of a love story with a breakup and
all that and the ideas are really
interesting to me and it's at some point
also it occurred to me that I had taught
my one term at cat at Cal I taught a
writing course my favorite student was a
kid named Oren diverse key and
turns out to be Amos Tversky the oldest
son and very quickly when I said you
know I might want to explore this is a
story I got in touch with when I said to
Danny they opened it up to me more or
less Danny was very dubious about about
the whole thing that the Tversky family
opened the doors today mrs. files and I
started beavering away on this one kind
of 2008-2009 I've been doing ever since
and finally worked up in there of a
couple of years ago to write it point
did you decide that this was going to be
a book only a few years ago I mean I
worked and worked and worked on it and
they got sick of me being very Danny
Kahneman asked going back and forth
about whether I my problem was I had I
had a couple of big problems one was I
didn't know I could pull it off I didn't
know I was a stranger to their field I
didn't I never had as much as a
introductory psychology course and I was
going to get my mind around their
position in the field and I was a [ __ ]
writing about the early Israeli state
and I thought do I have any business
doing that and I can imagine the million
people telling me exactly how I got it
wrong after I polished it so I I was
reluctant but made five to ten days each
before I committed to do the book that's
how that's how how much kind of legwork
I did before I even thought yeah I can
do the book but it was three or three or
four three years ago or so I finally
said I'd do it and I liked what I
concluded was their story was so
interesting enough people thought it was
important that someone was going to do
it and it was interesting enough that it
was just it was justified doing it and I
thought that anybody who's going to do
this is not going to have the access to
the material that I've had already open
open access to the Tversky family and
it's filed dannegan forthcoming with me
in a way he's never with anybody else
and so someone's going to do it Netaji
under badly and I said to Danny who was
good who went back and forth about
whether I should do this or not
I said look someone's gonna write a book
about you maybe after you're gone it's
probably going to be bad and you're not
going to like it so if someone's going
to write a bad
it might as well be naked right and you
know me you like me it may be bad it
might only mean why not me if I'm going
to write the bad book and he said that's
probably right he said all of that is
probably right it's probably going to be
a bad book and it's so on and so forth
but so that's it came about it came
about very hesitantly it was unlike any
of the other books I've done most of
other books I've spotted the subject and
in three or four months I'm in it and at
least is a magazine article and I didn't
that's not the way this work so in yet
how did you mcdaniel presumably was
going to him for about whether this was
a good idea and your relationship with
him evolved how many n did you persuade
him that he should really go along with
it just as you said that just as I said
he would say that his I knew so when
Danny day is the human embodiment of
doubt and he brought his whole life he's
there's nothing stable and he has an
idea he becomes wedded to it for a few
hours and he turns on it
it's in his lives his life that way
almost not almost resisting commitment
to anything and I think it's partly that
he doesn't like to defend things and but
he when he would put it is I like to
change my mind
this makes it very difficult for people
who are collaborating with him yes and
they fit and the stories are legendary
about the paper is about to go to the
publication he calls his gut poet he's
going to ruin our reputations and and
and a man used to do this with Amos and
Amos would sit with a drink in his hand
with friends saying let's wait for the
call get a call accompanied talking down
and then them and the paper would go in
and I just I thought I'm going to have a
problem because if I get in the middle
of this and he turns and changes his
mind it's going to be a lot of wasted
effort so the fallback position was
always it's not the question isn't a
book is going to be written and I come
here and someone's going to write the
book so this is this is that I get
better you know you know I'm at least
fond of you
so so that's I think that was the
selling point he was never happy with
the idea he never was really excited
that I was writing a book about him
anyway when he got it he
really not excited and in reddit i
meanit's he all of us all of the
subjects of all my books and had just
mount this jolt when they read it and I
tell them all that jolt you feel you're
gonna feel even if I got it exactly
right remember the first time you heard
your voice on tape you didn't sound like
you you're going to have that feeling a
little bit and it doesn't mean I got it
right but at least ask the people who
know and love you whether I got it right
before you get really angry at me
and so we've gone through that process
where he thought oh this isn't quite
right and then I said yep it is right
and yes you can come in for tonight I
spoke to one academic he'll be nameless
who had done joint work with with Danny
Aneesa he said Danny is the most
difficult person I have ever had to deal
with so what was a most his secret to
create this this extraordinary creative
partnership whether you described in the
book how they would just sit day after
day in a room with no one else in the
room people would hear them outside
talking and laughing and then suddenly
these great thoughts and ideas would
come out how did a must manage to pull
off working with Danny it was painful
and difficult I think sometimes because
nothing was stable but I think they
totally did so Amos Tversky is one of
the most interesting characters I've
ever encountered
it was difficult and first thing I was
going to bring this guy back to life but
he sends such a vivid they died in 96 of
my janitors in age 59 right now and he
but he sends such vivid signals even
from the grave because he never did
anything he didn't want to do anything
or never saved a piece of paper he
didn't want to save so there's no noise
it's all everything you get from him
anything saved in his filing cabinet any
friend he had any party he went to he
was there because he wanted to get to be
there and that included his relationship
with Danny had difficult as it was so he
wants to be in it because he senses
quite rightly there's a very very
fertile mind who's generating ideas that
does no-one else will have and it it's
just the grist for their mill was I
think Danny's just idea generating
machine
how he how he made the relationship work
well first there was a there weren't
many there aren't many people in the
history of Danny in whom danny has
unconditional stakes or trust in their
minds he was even Danny was awed by a
mrs. mind he everybody said that there
was a famous dick Nisbet to michigan
psychologist designed the one line
intelligence test and it was about Amos
Tversky he said the longer it takes you
to figure out after you've met Amos that
he's smarter than you the stupider you
are and everybody everybody who knew
Amos felt that way and and Danny was
aware that this was just this very
powerful magician what he was and so he
gave you Danny a sense of security it
wasn't I think they thought he's always
the day is always worried something's
wrong with this but if Amos approved of
it it must be right I think that was
part of the dynamic so Amos settled him
down that way and Amos was also
supremely confident
so he made Danny feel confident and Amos
for a stretch anyway up until they
basically get to this country I think
treated Danny's all of his ideas I kind
of leaned critically they get never the
kind of unconditional love and Danny
responded very well to that so it wasn't
magic in that I think that Danny you
know the taming of Danny for ten years
is one of the miracles of the
relationship and the ability to kind of
keep him from from from flipping on them
on the ideas but anyway so the Amos
spent a night when I was going through a
mrs. files cabinets they're always there
breakup letters with Danny in them
they're there I mean is this drama in
the file cabinets and among in the pot
the signs of the drama when there were
these stack of papers that were clearly
actually some of the real mark
preparation
the phone call of Danny and and it would
be bullet points of all the things Danny
was gonna be upset about and Amos is
response the arguments he was going to
make in response and this clearly
happened over and over and over and so
he spent a lot of time and now a mistake
didn't I mean in an extremely did
nothing he didn't didn't want to do he
would he would take his wife to the
movies and if he didn't like the movie
after five minutes it'll ever go home
and watch Hill Street Blues and go back
and get her at the end of the movie he'd
say they already took my money then I
get my time and he said he said you told
people you should never stay in a board
meeting or a faculty meeting or even a
party if you're not if you don't want to
be there and you don't have to pick up
as an excuse he says if you just get up
and walk it's amazing how the mind comes
up with the word to explain why you're
leaving and and that he was just
unbelievably efficient with what I mean
it really kind of in a preternatural way
and yet he was willing to endure this
relationship and I thought that was a
powerful statement about what he thought
of Danny what there's lots of practical
advice in the words of Amos knowing
Danny there's no practical advice from
from Danny but aim was yes so Amos says
at one point he said if you want to do
research it's good idea to be in a
permanent state of underemployment it is
better to waste hours than to end up
wasting lives yes this is very good
advice and to giving yourself time to
think
don't rush around being busy I can't
tell you how many people I've met who
were terribly busy I thought they must
be very important as a result yeah but
it doesn't follow it doesn't have any
ideas absolutely crucial yeah it can be
temperament to to some of their their
ideas or their work so what you
described in the book is a process in
which they start working first of all on
how people behave how they make
judgments and what these people do is to
say well you know economic economics has
become a very deductive discipline you
make certain assumptions of beginning
which no one really understood
but they sound very you know plausible
and then you make lots of deductions
about what constitutes rational behavior
and what they do is to do lots of
experiments which show that actually
people don't behave like that and it
takes a long time to persuade economists
that maybe people don't behave in the
way that economists normally assume so
they study these biases behavioral
biases that you described in the book
and then they move on to say well now
we've identified some of the biases
let's ask a different question which is
how do people make decisions they make
judgments and they may get these things
wrong they don't understand probability
but how do they make decisions and what
intrigued me about it was that both in
the words a few times of a loss but
particularly when you describe what
their work means to us thinking about
real world situations you bring in the
idea of people telling stories so it's
not just based on mathematics it's
people telling stories and there in fact
there is a quote on page 250 where you
actually quote Danny on this occasion
saying no one ever made a decision
because of a number they need a story so
how far do you think economics or social
sciences should move away from the more
rigorous mathematical views and the use
of numbers towards encouraging us all to
tell us story huh
afraid you may ask me a question like
this I'm back you're back as your
student and I'm about to get a
seat-filler spoken I don't have much
should you know in me I don't I don't
and you know it one of the things that's
interesting about their work in the way
it found its way into economics is it
wasn't clearly wasn't intentional in the
beginning that they didn't think they
were addressing economics that they
thought they were addressing decision
theory which was a weird branch of
psychology which happened to share with
economics of assumptions about human
behavior that man was a good intuitive
stew statistician whoever there was some
overlap there but it's only kind of
midway through their relationship that
Amos wakes up in a big way to the
implications for economics and
is the slowest of all I mean even now he
claims never did he intend the influence
economic so they gave him a Nobel Prize
for it so so I don't think Amos would
have said that that the assumptions of
an economic economist make are useless
they serve the purpose of the models and
the models can their tools these are
tools the Amos would have said that
maybe it's going to get even more
interesting it would be even more
interesting to try to adapt the models
to actually actual human behavior rather
than this theoretical economic man you
dreamed up but he was aware that it
created horrible problems for economics
and that he was vastly increasing the
workload for economists and he was very
sympathetic to economist who said this
is just too much trouble for us now and
economics does do a lot it's very useful
you know I I was the course of study I
pursued at the London School of
Economics has been there are a whole lot
of ideas that I took on board then very
useful ideas and these were all ideas
that they were all generated by people
who were assuming rationality and man so
I don't think I don't think the lesson
from dating this is you go you check out
economics you find a storytelling
approach was they within that quote that
was the passages quoted with Danny was
saying is he'd gone to a sickness when
he goes to the Israeli Foreign Minister
and shows him just it shows him the best
probability estimates of what will
happen how Arab countries will respond
if the Israelis do not walk away from a
peace negotiation and and the estimates
are like ten percent increase in the
probability of war and the foreign
minister says that ten percent is
nothing necessity and and that is the
number didn't mean any to me that's
where they walk away from this this this
field called decision analysis which was
stillborn basically and it was stillborn
they decided because people
of importance they don't want the power
being taken away from them by an
algorithm or by probability estimates
and they do want to think in stories so
that's not exactly an answer your
question except that except that might
take away from my experience with them
is not that economics is in need of
serious reform that isn't bad at all
anyway
so be - though we going to reflect try I
try i bullshitted my way through a good
principal student a good princess do you
think Danny's now at Princeton he's
either a Meredith you think that Mary
blocks from here is where our lives
so did winning a Nobel price do you
think change his views about he cannot
make so his own research or when did his
own life transformed him it's that one
of the things I was told by all the
Israelis who knew him win is that one of
my problems as a writer was going to be
the person I met was unrecognisable
would get to meet what did the person
they knew back then that he was far less
gloomy and troubled and it was almost
not exactly a sunniness about him but he
was just easier with the world around
him and that the summit of the Nobel
Prize edge and you know you'll think of
it changing a person kind of basic
demeanor but apparently it had I don't
think so it's changed his relationship
to the world other than that that's the
big that was the big effect it had so
remove some of the self doubt that he
had it really kind of story it's at the
a maroon the book for a bit but but in
the interest of this moment he so one of
the things that ripped apart the
relationship was at the minute they came
to North America Amos was recognized as
a global academic superstar he and
gained and Danny didn't wasn't given the
time of day
Amos gets the fastest appointment I'm
told by Stanford ever made in the
history of Stanford they find out he's
available in the morning and they're
offered him a lifetime employment by the
afternoon and Danny is an offer
by anybody some British Columbia
University of British Columbia
Amos gets almost instantly a MacArthur
Genius prize alone for the work they did
together I mean it goes on and on Amos
lived in fear he's going to get the
Nobel Prize alone I mean they and he
drunk he got the Nobel Prize and I
interviewed someone who's with I mean
the MacArthur prize he was in Israel
when it was notified the person was with
him said he was livid he said how could
they do this it's going to rip the
relationship apart dead so Danny was
already full of self-doubt and the world
is telling him that Amos is the genius
and Amos didn't do quite enough to to
address the problem and that starts to
tear at the relationship anyway Amos
dies in 1996 and Nobel Prize are not
given to the dead if you have to be
alive to get it and the work is
seemingly regarded as officially
important that the Nobel Committee is
considering giving it to Danny the prize
and in 2001 he gets a call saying they
want you to come and give a talk in
Stockholm and Danny interprets it says
they think the work is important enough
of the prize but they don't believe I
had anything to do with it that was an
audition for me to show them that I was
worthy of the prize which whether it's
true or not this is what's going on on
his head
and so he goes and gives a talk that has
nothing to do with their work to show
that his own work is worthy that he's he
was a kind of person he might have
contributed to this work
and the sort of cephalus self doubt he
is the the day the prize is announced
the day the prize was announced he he
his wife waiting by the phone and
printed in New Jersey because they think
this may be it and the phone doesn't
ring
he's telling he tells me he tells me the
story that his whole life his imagine
his imagination has been his fantasy
life that wasn't his fantasy life has
been so vivid
that that he's careful about what he
Santa sizes about because when he
fantasizes about it it's just a lot as
if he's experienced it and that this
began when he was a child in the
Holocaust
hiding from Nazis in chicken coops and
barns with his mom and dad in the South
of France and that he had fantasies
about single-handedly defeating the
German army and the alkylated as a kid
in it through adult life that he had
these very different sentences and there
were so many say sound that we
fantasized about something he wanted it
actually reduced his motivation to go
get it because it was as if he already
had it and he wanted the Nobel Prize so
badly that you didn't allow himself to
fantasize about it and so he's sitting
there waiting for this call about this
thing he's not allowed himself to
imagine himself getting because maybe
he's not worthy and lick phone doesn't
ring and his wife gets up and says you
know it's not going to happen that's too
bad she's English so she keeps a brief
and and and she goes off to go exercise
and he allows himself to fantasize about
what he would have done had he won the
Nobel Prize and what he would have done
with all the things for Amos that Amos
would never do for him that he would he
would he would give his talk at the
Nobel Prize with a giant photograph of
Amos bonnet and you bring a mrs. wife
and children with him he would talk
about him but he would append the eulogy
he gave at a mrs. funeral to his Nobel
Prize acceptance speech he would he
would give Amos all the credit in the
way Amos never gave him all the credit
and he's sitting there allowing himself
to fantasize about it and the phone
rings at the end of book is it's
wonderful now many authors write one
successful book very few manage a second
third fourth let alone thirteen what is
the secret would you found to be the
secrets of writing consistently books
that people really enjoy reading a kind
of exquisite god-given talent you
extremely old which nobody could
actually enter late to hope to aspire to
so there's no point really even talking
it certainly it certainly fits the fact
that's so observation equivalent to
reality my career is full of serendipity
it's incredibly lucky that I end up at
Salomon Brothers in the middle of the
80s boom with that kind of material at
hand as a naive kid who kind of wants to
be a writer and but the that I've been
it I've been I start out very lucky and
the luck has has compounded the luck in
the beginning has given me access to
stories I never would have had access to
the reason the Oakland A's are willing
to talk to me they read liars poker
the reason Danny's willing to talk to me
is I got all these other books I've
written that he's been easy just thought
something of the so there's um so how'd
you decide what to write about so what I
care a lot about I have to care so much
about it if I care a lot about it I have
to see either there is always a feeling
before a book and that before I decide
it's a book and I have to have the
feeling and the feeling is isn't about
me it's about the subs the material and
I've been entrusted with it and and and
I've got I have an obligation to tell
the story well don't screw it up so
that's the feeling with which I need to
go in because it's miserable doing the
book and so I have to be able to go back
in that you have a responsibility to
tell the story now the general gift of
gab and ability to put sentences on the
page and all that I mean it that's
developed over time I was never I wasn't
until I met you as a graduate student
maybe six months or a year before I
didn't have any ambition to be a writer
it was really I got out of college at I
figured anybody could school newspapers
and knowing those people ping glitch -
you ever thought I was a gifted writer
I got a D in English my sophomore year
in high school there are many many
former teachers of mine who view my
career is the way people view Donald
Trump being president like something's
wrong in the world if he's in that stage
I wrote a book The Blind Side about the
family in Memphis Tennessee so you know
if you probably saw the movie anyway he
didn't read the book and the guy the
main character in that movie the father
of the
that the character that she's named
Shawn tui at tim mcgraw played when i
when i was my student run was my
classmate for 13 years at the ended or
neumann school in new orleans louisiana
kindergarten through twelfth grade and
as you said the only prize you and i got
when we got out with the prize for DNA
for 13 years and that was absolutely
true and when when i saw him when i in
the encounter that led me to find the
story of the blindside his first
question to me was who likes your books
and I and I said I said I said I do and
he says that's [ __ ] he said you're
the dumbass in the back of the class
with me there's no way you were the
Cohen just telling me who wrote you
honestly could not get his mind around
the possibility that I had put pen to
paper or sat at a computer and generated
words that were this coherent and he was
so there's an huge there's an accidental
quality his career and it has had this
compounding effect that it gets easier
and easier in a weird way to get access
to the things you need to write the good
story
alright notice in all your books there's
quite a large biographical element
people live large
there's always men what's unusual is
that there's always a serious story plot
line as well but it's also people this
merging of the two
but you've never really written a book
about conventional successful people get
the great hero you haven't written a
book about Napoleon or oh you know that
yeah that's true so what why have you
stay away from that subject matter and
honed in on people but none of us before
we open the book would ever imagine
wanting to read above well there's no
need for that story that we may leave
our gift comes back to the other extent
of obligation that that they're going to
be 100 books about Donald Trump or about
you know because I did a little piece
about Obama that was the closest I got a
magazine the magazine Pia but the
and if so that I think that's the big
thing as a who needs me for that there's
there are lots of people who can do
those things
this finding the onion the finding the
meaningful story no one realizes is
meaningful is is is the trick for me and
seeing the meaning in it and waking the
world up to it is my role so if
everybody is already awake to the
importance of it's comfortable it's just
hard for me to get excited about it it's
not stating would never happen but it's
funny when my career started I have a
friend who was seven or eight years
ahead of me a Theodore name in school
named Walter Isaacson who has been head
of the Aspen Institute now and at former
editor Time magazine is written by a
piece of Steve Jobs and Henry Kissinger
and Einstein and Franklin and so on and
so forth so Walter Isaacson who's
wonderful he's a wonderful writer it was
as I remember the child he was the most
successful person anybody knew he was a
user you went to Harvard he was a Rhodes
Scholar nut everything went right every
two years the headmaster brought him
into the Newman school to tell us what
we should be when we grew up and by the
by our about tenth grade we were
sticking our fingers down throat we walk
in and so I had the first piece of
advice Walter Osmond gave me after I
wrote liars poker was now you need to
ride your book about the great a great
man uh-huh
and I thought no that's not what I'm
that's not what I'm going to do that's
what you do yeah and I just never felt
it that it's the it never felt the
slightest inclination to do it it bore
the idea bores me so that's not a good
start for a literary project to be bored
by the idea there's always a lot of
serendipity and as you said earlier but
you can't be purely passive you must go
out and look for interesting stories you
don't yeah you don't sit at home and
they come like manna from heaven how do
you go about looking for stories and
what is it that when you see a story
trigger something in your mind that says
I need to find out more about this this
could be an interesting story it usually
is a really simple question I mean with
this is how did I miss that I mean I was
like how did I not think about what was
going on in the mud
these people who were making these
systematic misjudgment semana D that's
an obvious question I didn't ask it so
this was an oversight on my part but the
I mean I'll just go one by one with
Moneyball it was there's this baseball
team that's got a fifth the resources of
the New York Yankees winning as many
games as the New York Yankees
if this market is efficient how on earth
are they doing that and that I didn't
think it was a book I thought maybe was
a magazine piece and I wouldn't ask them
the question and the answer was just
breathtakingly interesting and so
usually starts with some curiosity like
that and it leads me into a place and
then the interest mushrooms and it
mushrooms it has to for the book for it
to be a book after mushroom in very
specific ways I have to find characters
that I find have literary dimensions to
them and in situations that are really
compelling and they have to be willing
to let me hang around so it's it isn't
there's no system to it I'm not scouring
this paper is looking for what the next
book is I don't know what the next book
is right now I almost never do and it's
so it is it and they're likely to get it
from a dinner planning of an idea from a
dinner party as I am preventing or a
conversation with a friend or as from a
where else it's not a systematic process
it's a haphazard process it really is
serendipity it is I'm really I'm wait so
the way I feel what I'm looking for even
if I never really look for books subject
to kind of find me one way or the other
but I tell my kids my kids I've got my
kids my kids are 17 14 and 9 and they're
very intelligent and even so I have
persuaded that I have a gift for finding
parking spots in in that in that very
hard to park day area and I'll say it
will go to restaurants there's not gonna
be problems gonna be a parking spot
right there now it's 1 out of 10 times
there's one there but it happens often
enough then they think oh he must have
easily actually have a talent for
finding a parking spot and that it's
just a parking lot but that's right it
counted out vascular a hole too so
so the my gift for finding stories is a
similar sort of thing it's like I'm
gonna wander around and I'm elite I kind
of half believe myself I have a gift for
finding stories and we are then one
opens up fantastic
well it's certain the conversation up
now to our audience it would like to ask
questions there are roving microphones
is one over there on the straight out of
this gentleman and the light through
shirt one here just put your hand up
again sir and then sit the microphone
will come to you and then others on this
side who would like yes one there okay
go ahead thanks so much thanks so much
for coming arm I'm very curious so Danny
Kahneman doesn't seem like the kind of
guy who just opens up to anyone so and
you were somehow able to build this very
trusting relationship with them and he
trusted you to give you all this
information I'm curious on how you were
able to do that and maybe you can start
like the FIR how was the first meeting
you had with them and what did you do to
try to get him to open up to you um I
didn't do it consciously in the
beginning cuz I didn't think I was gonna
be writing that I just was going to go
seek Him and talk about like the
relationship between his work and his
book I written so I walked in his front
door the first time he's in purple
crocks and and he looks like in an
Israeli shirt and he's kind of like very
casual and I said I think I said
something like I'm honored to meet you
and he said look to me strangely say he
said oh do you mean the Nobel Prize
that's not don't worry about that if
that's dumb don't don't don't stand on
and he was very he he made the
interaction very easy right away but he
was agonizing over this book and we
quickly were talking about his book and
he's giving me stuff to read and not
talk to say what I thought about it and
all the rest and advise him on how to
deal with his publisher and whatever was
in [ __ ] my Buitoni it had a natural
subject of conversation he for his
exercise he was then this was a 2008 he
was in 76 he would basically race walk
through the hills of Berkeley he had
time himself ever since he was a little
kid he would cook he would time himself
on walks around his gardens and
try to beat his own time he's not an
athlete but he's very competitive and so
I go on these race walks with him and he
started saying things so interesting I
used to bring a notepad and I said I
don't know what i'ma do with this the
kindest write stuff down and I'd be
walking and you know that's that's how
that was the next stage and then finally
he said you know there may be a story in
this can I just you know you okay with
that and he was coming I don't even know
if he ever said yes but he never said no
and he never never rigorously went
through his life story with me
everything I got I got a nugget here and
nugget there and his memory would be
triggered by things so I was gathering
stuff they're in a very unsystematic way
from him over eight years and it
couldn't have happened fast if I had
been if it had been a more
straightforward reporter subject
relationship it would glass at five
minutes and it had no interested in the
great trick though to getting people who
are interesting to cooperate with you in
this kind of project or anything is to
be interesting to them and useful so I
do this with all subjects I mean I'm not
doing it I just do it come naturally and
that stuff is not a done ploy but if you
can somehow be helpful to them and fun
to be around
it's amazing how much easier it is to be
around them so the with the Oakland A's
I mean it a money Bowl that I would I
would report what was going on in the
clubhouse to the front office and I
would tell the players what was going on
in the front office and they always
wanted to see me because they know they
wouldn't talk to each other and Danny
Danny became riveted in what was coming
out on a Miss his file cabinets I mean
he had these letters these love letters
they had written to each other I mean
then she knows and you know and she
didn't know every didn't have anything
did all of his papers had burned up in
the Oakland Fire of 1989 so he had no
and it was just triggering memory after
memory I was having in reliving this
relationship
and he was interested in that question
back there middle summer right and one
down here yep Howard look Thank You fati
people have different opinions a lot
Danny said that wouldn't have been
written because Amos would have
disapproved of it this whole to system
thing is little little homunculus
a masseuse said that's a metaphor and
it's and Amos didn't like metaphors Amos
thought metaphors were tools for
deception and so I I think that whether
Danny would listen to him I don't know I
mean if famous were alive a lot of other
things might happen I mean presumably
they would have gotten the Nobel Prize
together and I mean they might so here's
the easy answer the question actually
they from the very beginning had this
sense that their work should be
popularized that there was a broader
audience outside of just narrow
psychology journals for this stuff and
they went back and forth forever on this
project even when they were busted up
there were some memos back and forth and
they can never get it off the ground
they were always killing it and they
were both responsible for it so I think
the honest answer is that wouldn't of
the book wouldn't be written it would
still be that book is the book they
would have written to get it together
and they were can write it so I think it
was just not happened yes gentlemen here
so there's a line in the book where I
think Danny talks about comparing a
human being to being an organism that's
equipped with like an affective and
hormonal system that's similar to a
jungle rat having the ability to kind of
push buttons of mass destruction or
something very similar to that right I'm
kind of curious kind of given the
current political climate what Amos
would actually think in terms of his
prediction on the election and whether
or not he would feel that it was kind of
justified based upon the type of a
rationality as well as
you know the set of cognitive biases
that are going on how he would filter
this experience he firstly would say
that you take a great pleasure in
people's inability to predict the
election he wouldn't himself have any
prediction or if he did it keep it
private and say I know that this
probably [ __ ] but he would say that
this is you know that this is these
people are there they think the future
is more knowable than it is they think
the world is a more certain place than
it is
Amos is what it was a great lovely line
he said reality is not a point it's a
cloud of possibilities and that we're
always in a probabilistic situation even
we don't know it and we insist on making
these determining seemingly they could
feel like a deterministic situation to
the point where after the fact when
something really really shocking happens
we go back and tell a story about how it
was inevitable and we explain that which
we can't predict with nothing more no
more information other than the outcome
and we do it over and over and over he
left he left a room like this filled
with historians ashen-faced by
explaining to them what was going on in
their minds in their work and how that
was there was a there was a huge fallacy
a part of it so he would have first
thing you're going to take great
pleasure in how nobody and how people
even appalled by Trump but that's a
separate thing that's not that's not
original he he would have been along
with Danny taking great interest in the
way people undid the election like a
tragedy was they were exploring the
rules of the imagination with their
undoing project when they broke up and
they were the way people under something
that they didn't like that happened like
and the way people were undoing it
instantly followed the rules that they
had described they undid the emails they
did the Comey the FBI's letter directors
letter and the first rule of the undoing
project Floyd you start at the end of
the calls okay and you work back and you
want to do the first thing you can undo
to undo the outcome to reverse the
outcome without regard to the
probabilities involved so there was no
greater than 50% chance that Donald
Trump was born a girl but nobody thinks
that only Donald Trump was born a girl
they think if only James Comey had not
really
had that stirred up trouble a week
before the election there are lots of it
they're doing in different scenarios in
which Donald Trump is not president the
people focus on a couple and they need
to take an interest in how they do that
and what they were doing and Danny would
have been very interested in this too
they would have been I think probably
really interested in the way in Trump's
appeal and it's the appeal of all people
who are willing to appear confident
about things that are unknowable and
certain about things that are unknowable
and and and he prays actually pretty
pretty successfully on these kind of
weaknesses in the human mind you know
people think in stereotypes rather than
statistically so you tell a story about
a Mexican immigrant who's murdered
somebody and and nobody thinks oh what
are the stats on that or Mexican
immigrants actually more likely than
anybody else to murder an American they
think no they have an image Muslim
terrorists you see that you he's always
bouncing from stereotype to stereotype
and people do the point isn't the name
is Dan's point in in the thinking in
sternums isn't racism sexism is people
actually think in these classifications
you may you have to resist them and
Trump doesn't resist any of that so they
would have I think they would have had
something he'd had something to say
about that but but I don't I don't think
his actual feelings about Trump himself
would be that different from a lot of
people's question there I'm curious you
mentioned that there are a lot of things
that have to go right in order for you
to write a story what's the closest
you've come to writing a story without
actually writing it and why did you
decide to not write it I getting two big
cases one was I was when I sold
Moneyball I sold it was two books and
where there was going to be a sequel and
I spent the better part of three years
chasing around after minor league
baseball players to the point where I
was actually in uniform in the double-a
Midland
jams shagging flyballs before the game
and shouting from instructions from the
dugout and I thought I thought I was
going to trace through the kids the
Oakland A's had drafted by algorithm the
what happened with the route with the
ideas and the revolution if there was a
revolution but the problem was Moneyball
we got so noisy and people were there
was so much stuff written about it that
it felt it devoured my own story so I I
put a huge amount of work into that and
it just came to nothing so instead of
writing a sequel and as I ended up
running the prequel which is what this
is in a way the other one the one that
got away which violates a bit would
contradict a bit what I was saying
earlier about not being interested in in
in great men famous people George Soros
you know who he is so most of the hedge
fund manager but also that in the early
nineties of the creator of the open
society network in Eastern Europe I
spent a couple of weeks with him roaming
his empire and writing a magazine piece
about it and it was a kid he was a book
at that moment he was a great great
great book and he agreed to let me write
it so let me just trail around behind
him and then he read the magazine piece
I wrote and the magazine piece was very
flattering about him but dismissive of
his intellectual life and he has great
theories to explain basically his animal
instincts and there they just I think
seem like nice talking nonsense and fact
but and I quite admire him and he did
not like the way I treated his ideas and
he pulled the plug on it
and that that's a great shame I could
have done a lot with him as a subject at
that moment in history and it was spoken
it would it would still it would be
evergreen I think that so I I was really
sorry to lose that one I think there's
only one way we can really bring this to
a close and that's to put this test of
serendipity and three people
I get three people a chance in two
sentences to suggest what the subject
and Michael's next book should fit
anyone anyone want to come up with a
median system we have one right here
they did yeah women great women but I
don't even write about great men I would
I needed lenio little women right any
women who are obscure within some
interesting situation my publicist from
my publishers right behind you and she
says I'm incapable of fighting women
accurately so so so so it's so that
maybe maybe it's just beyond me I can
only do you know if men are dogs and
women are cats
it was dogs easy they hungry and their
tires and that's it and those are my
characters nice simple counter that
simple guys and women are complicated
and I can't get my mind around them but
I'm with you if a story opened up that I
could put the quote well the blindside
had a woman at the end of it but if
another one opened up I would be biased
to doing it that it's just a question of
the material being there take two more
suggestions yes there's one that men are
cystic personality disorder and now we
have a president that might have nurses
to Christmas lighting this is a weird
weird dude I mean we are talking about
we have not plumbed the depths of his
weirdness and that's it so but I think
that if you really look at that as a
mental disorder
don't be how it flows through different
corporations and all decisions are made
I think that's an area doctoral meeting
it's a really good topic but who's the
character well there I know because
there are a lot of yeah there's but that
would be your job to find who would give
a fascinating person with narcissistic
personality disorder that could burn
through it right now is Holly trumpets
you know it would be a fascinating if
you really look at on the spectrum what
is what entails and then you could
almost predict how behavior and decision
being made sorry but they can have one
more suggestion one more this side yes
the other way is another well you first
have to tell me what it is the UFC the
fight that's I just I find that stuff so
depressing I do
I don't doesn't it doesn't as people
shouldn't be hitting each other in a
cage so is it so it's hard for me to
want to draw more attention to it yeah
well we're not doing terminal were like
coming up with great some no I thought I
think it's so perfect well I think
though what we've learned tonight is why
it is that whatever Michael writes we
all millions of us enjoy reading it
you're only in New York for a day I know
Michael but thank you so much for coming
to Stern it's been absolutely
fascinating and there could be no better
Christmas present from all the your
loved ones holiday the Michaels book and
he will be signing the books at the back
afterwards
in the meantime on your behalf let's st.
Michael very much the Kinetoscope if you
like a little tend to help you write
your next report thank you
[Applause]